Donald Trump said this week that he
would not appoint a Supreme Court
justice to try to rollback same-sex
marriage victory right well no not
really because despite president-elect
Trump saying that same-sex marriage is
settled he also said that he wants to
appoint justices who would challenge the
1973 abortion rights ruling roe versus
wade one of those conservative judges is
William Pryor jr. I talked to you a
little bit about him before the election
and in the past he suggested that
same-sex couples who think about this
same-sex couples should be punished with
jail for having sex in their own homes
doesn't exactly sound like small
government conservatism to me and he
defended a law in 2003 in Texas which
criminalizes consensual gay sex
comparing it to quote polygamy incest
pedophilia prostitution and adultery
Pryor also argued that LGBT people
aren't even protected by the United
States Constitution can you imagine
someone on the Supreme Court who
believes that based on your sexual
orientation the Constitution may not
protect you he said in a legal brief
about the law that states should be able
to criminally charge gay people for
having sex here is a quote from William
H Pryor jr. the Supreme Court has never
recognized a fundamental right to engage
in sexual activity outside of monogamous
heterosexual marriage let alone to
engage in homosexual sodomy such a right
would be antithetical to the traditional
relation of the family that is as old
and as fundamental as our entire
civilization that's only the beginning
here is where it gets even more nuts
it's not just about male anal sex as it
often is for homophobes he also defended
straight people's right to have anal sex
so it is really specifically about
homosexuality quote Texas is hardly
alone in concluding that homosexual
sodomy may have severe physical
emotional psychological and spiritual
consequences which
not necessarily attend heterosexual
sodomy and from which Texas's citizens
need to be protected very often you hear
from the right that the problem is is
sodomy right anal sex and and as defined
in some states oral sex but prior went
further than that
he actually said you know it's not even
really the sexual act specifically that
are the problem those same sexual acts
are fine for heterosexual couples to
participate in it is the gay couples
that can't participate there and here is
the last concern about this as if there
aren't many he uses the term spiritual
consequences Pat if you're using the
term spiritual consequences in a
statement about what civil law should do
that is by its very nature church and
state not being separated
you should never consider spiritual
consequences that more than likely are
only relevant to one or two or some
limited number of particular religions
in figuring out what the law should be
this guy is a danger and this is who
Trump would consider putting on the
Supreme Court and so much for respecting
the First Amendment because Thomas
Jefferson said that separation of church
and state actually is a defended right
by the Constitution yeah and I guess you
could kind of look at him as a
progressive in some sort of way because
the biblical expectation for
homosexuality is that you're put to
death oh yeah nice silver lining hey at
least he doesn't want to kill gay people
that's certainly something when the
silver lining is they don't want gay
people killed you know that we've hit
rock bottom and Pryor has also defended
not allowing same-sex couples to adopt
kids you've got to be pretty depraved to
say hey there's all these kids who need
a loving family there's no study that
says there's anything negative in terms
of its consequences for kids in turn
when there is same-sex adoption and he
says no just based on sexual orientation
they cannot adopt